what up space fam goes in here from
anime outboard back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest updates
in the one piece story and we got some
crazy stuff in this one including the
appearance of the trader the
continuation of the hype seraphim fights
against the straw hats a very crazy
unexpected turn of events and much more
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy these one piece reviews
I want to keep them coming Channel
pirate king with it and smash that like
button with no mercy until you see
fireworks if you haven't make this the
video you joined the Knock Em Up by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications where you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into this
chapter called should have noticed
sooner spoilers and all we start at the
Egghead Factory where central Maru is
telling everyone they need to get off
the island satomaru explains that long
ago there was a place called Ohara and
it just vanished from the map because
they defied the world government like
that time sentimaru decides that the
fact that they are going after Mega Punk
the smartest man in the world means that
they've weighed the consequences and
decided it's time to erase him stuff we
knew but Oda wants to give us a sense of
what's going on around the island as
well said tomorrow then even adds that
an incident much worse than the Ohara
incident could happen here any time I
assume he means what happened to La
Lucia when it wasn't just the people who
were killed but the entire Island was
destroyed as if it had never existed in
a split second the thing that has been
preventing that though so far seems to
be the fact that the island in
particular is full of very useful
technology not to mention the seraphims
are on there right now and the
government wants their hands on the
seraphims and that technology but who
knows if things get bad enough they may
also launch an attack and erase this
island along with the inhabitants on it
and we don't know if there are even ways
that the seraphims could potentially
survive that attack but anyways this
adds an obvious sense of urgency to the
whole situation santomaru is thinking
that Luffy should hurry up already and
he's wondering what's taking so long and
I think we all agree with Santa Maru
especially after Luffy used gear 4 not
gear 5 to fight them in the last chapter
it seems like he's really taking a sweet
time like Goku and he just went Super
Saiyan sometimes to test out a fighter
instead of just going his final form
right away now we jump to the unlikely
teammates Luffy and Luchi taking on S
Bear keep in mind Luffy is not in gear 5
like I said but using gear 4 for
whatever reason the two launched
combined attacks and it seems like they
are landing solid hits in the meantime
as Hawk AKA many mihawk is still
fighting Kaku and Zoro Zoro launches an
attack and hits him but it's a one sword
attack so like Luffy he doesn't seem to
be going all out still and I'm not sure
what they're waiting for before they go
all out Luffy then even transforms back
to normal form and is shocked that their
attacks seem to have no effect on the
seraphims he's upset and screams that
they are getting up way too fast he says
enough already what are you guys kaido
so that's definitely High Praise
comparing these guys to their former
strongest creature in the world and the
former yonko with the highest Bounty of
course we can't take the words too
seriously since it took gear 5 Luffy to
barely overcome kaido while Luffy hasn't
used that yet here however the fact that
he is in normal form again suggests that
hopefully we may see him go serious soon
and just go from normal to gear 5 right
away Zoro then finally notices that they
kind of look like King and Daft Punk for
his part is surprised that kaido had a
lunarion on his crew that punk explains
what we also put together obviously that
the seraphims were strengthened by
King's lunarian blood and now in a
hilarious part Zorro finally realizes
that hey if that's the case keep an eye
on the flames on their backs our guys
attacks will only work when their flame
is out but when the fire is on they're
almost Invincible he then apologizes for
making them waste energy like that
saying he should have noticed sooner of
course these guys don't know exactly how
similarly these guys look to King so
Luchi just says it's fine at least they
know how to fight them now Zorro goes on
to explain that King's special features
were his white hair dark-skinned black
wings and flames on his back and then
everyone freaks out because yeah that's
too obvious bro he should have noticed
it sooner but still it's cool that
zoro's knowledge is helping out here
because if they didn't know that it it
could have been near impossible to beat
them that punk then starts leaving and
Luffy asks where is he going the
satellite responds that he thinks he has
an idea where Stella the main body might
be and man looking back on this after
knowing what's going to come at the end
of the chapter it just begs the question
why didn't he just say where he was
going but anyways more on that later we
then see little mihawk and Zoro Clash
again as Zorro says get out of our way
we're in a bit of a rush Zorro still
looks calmer than the seraphim but you
gotta admit this is taking longer than
we expected for these four characters we
then jump to Nami and just on a side
note you can bet the other groups are
going to be doing worse than Zorro and
Luffy but anyways back to Nami who not
surprisingly is having trouble with s
shark AKA little ground swimming dream
she uses Zeus in order to attack s shark
she's struggling with the fact that he
looks like a kid but she closes her eyes
and Zeus takes over and props to both of
them as shark actually looks pretty
damaged with smoke even coming from his
mouth Nami even apologizes to jinbei
showing that this is a a really bad
matchup for her not only does she feel
like she's attacking a kid but her
friend too then as shark uses the devil
fruit power to fall into the ground as
if it were water despite how damaging
the attack looked as shark is back at it
right away in no time appearing right
behind Nami Zeus is shocked that the
attack had no effect luckily Sanji comes
in the nick of time I also love it when
he says going by Article 1 of Sanji
land's Constitution scaring Nami is
punishable by death that's a funny and
also heartwarming thing for him to say
right here you can tell by his
expression that he's really mad and I
can't wait to see what really mad Sanji
is gonna do again he lands what looks
like a devastating hit on the seraphim
but it's hard to believe any hit is as
bad as it looks since they just keep
standing back up right away like Luffy
complained about I will say though Sanji
looks badass here and I love to see it
we then jump to Lilith launching an
attack at s snake and it's funny how
both nami's attack and her attack give
us a similar fan service angle you gotta
love how Odin doesn't even forget about
the fan service during battles to the
death Lilith's attack involves the
bubble gun and at first it looks like it
did nothing as wusah points out but that
s snake suddenly Falls over we then get
some very valuable information yes even
though they don't have the original
Fruit they are still affected by devil
fruit weaknesses which is fair I mean
you get the powers you get the
weaknesses as Lilith explains the reason
s snake fell down is because this bubble
is made from the energy of the sea very
cool in a world filled with powerful
devil fruit users who thought a bubble
gun could be such an OP weapon she then
points out that's the risk of having
green blood bubble is your weakness usab
cheers her on and Frankie moves into
subdue as snake while he has the chance
but gets kicked pretty badly by mini boa
Frankie is surprised the effect wore off
so quickly and Lilith explains that it's
because the attack just grazed her Oda
is definitely trying to emphasize as
snake's cuteness here since even her mad
face looks like something out of spy X
family as snake launch is one of those
powerful energy blasts we've been seeing
Lately from the seraphims and then
Frankie appears behind with a giant
bubble and brings it down onto a snake
now that the giant bubble is touching a
snake she really is subdued Lilith and
usop are celebrating and Frankie even
calls Lil boa a brat but the cutest
factor is real and as s snake says She's
suffering with tears in her eyes Frankie
can't help but feel sorry for her and
apologize in this way he lets his guard
down for a second and it's enough for
the seraphim to kick him and turn him
into stone something we've seen from Boa
before that as if Frankie turning to
Stone wasn't bad enough the seraphim
proceeds to wink and turn both Usopp and
Lilith to Stone as well with her powers
that appears to be the first Seraph in
Victory but it does not bode well
because now s snake can help one of the
other seraphims and so far all the
battles have not been looking good for
the straw hats yes we haven't seen Luffy
and Zorro go all out but so far the
seraphims as a whole are definitely
crushing the straw hats now I wonder if
these three will have a way to come back
from stone or if the straw hats will
somehow need to get snake on their side
to turn them back maybe even boa makes
an appearance at some point with this
turn of events to change them back
either way I'm excited to see how
Frankie and Usopp will be saved that's
definitely one of the bigger Mysteries
right now we then jump to the former
devil fruit laboratory underground that
punk has arrived where all the Cypher
pull people and Stella are being held
our Daft Punk is excited to see that
Stella was actually here he starts
running excitedly but then our precious
dad Punk is shot down he looks done
since it was a head shot to Stella's
shock the mysterious figure has finally
made himself known with this gunshot and
man that is really sad I'm going to miss
saying Daft Punk drink every one piece
review but back to the chapter and
everyone is in a panic now and the
narrator tells us that the only hope has
been shot down and I'm just thinking why
why did that bunk not let someone know
where he was going so they'd at least
know where to look if something like
this happened and he didn't come back
but at least it appears that we'll
finally see who the trader is
significantly though they aren't killing
Stella and they are kidnapping cyber
bull people so it clearly shouldn't be
anyone with the interest of the
government in mind which just raises the
interest level even more someone against
the world government but seemingly
against the straw hats as well let me
know your thoughts on who this is and
what their motivations could possibly be
but another mystery that has been solved
thankfully recently is that of Zorro's
parents we actually got zoro's full
family Tree revealed by Oda so click the
link on screen right now or in the
description to see for yourself zoro's
full and shocking Family Tree